Thanks for watching!
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Pahamnawerohomi, Abhyavajohomi, Anigohomi, Sukhiathananpariharami, Dukhamujami, Yathaladasampatitho, Mawikachami, Amakanchatupachayadayaka,
Avera hontu, abhya bhaja hontu, Aniga hontu, sukhya tanam pariharantu, Dukhamu chantu, yathalada sampatito, Mawika chantu.
Amaka marta apitu acharyan yati mita samuha Avera hantu abhya bhaja hantu Aniga hantu sukhya tanam hari haramtu
Dukhamu Chantu Yathaladha Sampatito Mawika Chantu Imasmin Vihare Sabeh Bhikkhu Saba Bhikkhu Ni Sabeh Acharya
Sabe yogino Avera hontu Abhya bhaja hontu Anika hontu Sukhi atanam Pari haramtu Dukhamu chantu Yathalada sampatito Mavika chantu
Arakadevata Averahontu Abhyavajahontu Anigahontu Sukhyatanam Hariharantu Dudukahuchantu Yathaladasampatito Mavikachantu
Imaslingame janapade Yoropaya lokasmin sabejanata Awerahontu abhyabhajahontu Anighahontu sukhiatanam pariharantu
Dukhamu Cantu Yathalada Sampatitho Mawika Cantu Puratimaya Disaya Pacimaya Disaya Putaraya Disaya Dakhinaya Disaya Puratimaya Ludhisaya Pacimaya Ludhisaya
Uttaraya Anudisaya Dakinaya Anudisaya Hetimaya Disaya Uparimaya Disaya
Sabe sata, sabe pana, sabe buta, sabe bukhala, sabe atavavapariya pana, sabe itiyo, sabe purisa, sabe ariya, sabe anariya, sabe deva, sabe manusa,
Sabe winipatika.
Awera hontu, Abhyabhaja hontu, Aniga hontu, Sukhi hatanam, Pariharantu.
Dukhamu chantu, Yathalata sampatito, Mawika chantu.
Metta Bhavana.
Developing goodwill, loving-kindness.
May you be safe, well and happy.
May you live contented, in harmony with the world.
So we can bring to mind some of our benefactors.
Those who are near and dear to us.
Friends, people at work, whomever we wish.
a neutral person towards ourselves
someone we have difficulties with towards each other
all those in our neighborhood, all the people in our country,
All the peoples of Europe.
All people on earth.
and to all beings in all directions Mudita, developing joy
The traditional blessings, may you be joyful, may you be ever more joyful, may you experience the bliss of Nibbana.
Let's bring to mind moments of joyfulness, happiness we've experienced today.
Let us wish ourselves to be joyful.
Let's bring to mind somebody we know who has cause to be joyful.
Wish them greater joy.
Let us bring to mind that at this moment there are people who are happy and content with their lives, who are enjoying the warmth of various types of friendship from intimate to acquaintance, who enjoy the delights of art, nature, sport, hobbies and so on, who find their work meaningful, who are reaping the fruitfulness of their spiritual practice,
and who rejoice in the success of others.
Let's offer our goodwill joy to all beings in all directions.
Pujachapujanianam etamanggalambuttamam.
Patirupadesavasuchapubechakatapunyata.
Atasamapanidicha etamanggalambuttamam.
Bahusachamchasipanchawinayochasusikitho.
Subhasita jaya wacha etamanggalam uttamam.
Mata pitu upatana buddha terasa sanggaho.
Anakulaca kamanta etamanggalam uttamam.
Daunam ca dhamma charya chanya takanam ca sanggaho.
A-na-wa-ja-ni-ka-ma-ni-e-ta-ma-ngal-ang-bu-ta-ma.
A-ra-ti-we-ra-ti-pa-pa-ma-cha-pa-na-cha-sa-nya-mo.
A-pa-ma-do-cha-da-me-su-e-ta-ma-ngal-ang-bu-ta-ma.
Ga-ra-wa-ja-ni-wa-to-cha-sa-tu-ti-cha-ka-ta-nyu-ta.
Kalena dhamma savanam etamangalam gutamam.
Kantica suvaca sata samananam ca dasanam.
Kalena dhamma sakapca etamangalam gutamam.
Tapuca brahmacaryaca aryasacca nadasanam.
Nibbāna sācci kīryācchā etta maṅgalam uttamam.
Bhūtā salokadāme hi citta yasana kāmpati.
Āsokam vīrajāṅ keman etta maṅgalam uttamam.
EDHA DISANI KADVANA SABHATTA MAPARAJITSA SABHATTA SULTINGA CHANTI KAMTESA MANGALAM UTTAMANTI
Sabe sata sukita hantu.
Sadhu, sadhu, sadhu.